hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show today we were talking
about mothers
with no boundaries we're talking about
co-workers with mental health challenges
and what to do
and we're going to talk about how to
find a therapist things to look for
things to be a little bit leery of and
more
stay tuned
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john dolone show
collar driven show we talk about real
things happen to real people
all the time talking about relationships
your relational iq your mental health
parenting we're talking about that
neighbor who always lets their dog
crap on your lawn or we're also going to
talk about that neighbor that puts signs
in their yard
that prohibit your dog from just doing
what your dog's got to do right i don't
know which one is worse but here's the
deal we're talking about all of it
so if you want someone to hear you if
you want a second opinion
if you want to know if you're crazy or
the people around you
aren't hearing the world so clearly
give me a call the advice will be worth
what you pay for it i'm here to walk
with you
call me at 1-844-693-3291 that is 1-844
or email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
that's ask john ramseysolutions.com
leave your number leave your name and
give me some insight as to what's going
on in your life
and kelly daniel will check the emails
out and she will get in touch with you
for being a part of this awesome show i
want to just take a moment and just tell
everybody we are
the first week has launched and wherever
this falls wherever this particular
episode falls in the queue just want to
tell you man
it has blown out of the gate it's blown
everybody's uh
thoughts away from what we thought this
thing was going to be it's been way
bigger it's done way better
your comments have been wonderful the
subscription rates have been high so
just want to take a moment and thank
every single person who's listened who
has given us these great reviews
on the podcast thank you so much and we
look forward to
10 or 20 more years yeah and the youtube
folks you guys came over with us from
what our other youtube show was and
i'm just so grateful so it's kind of
blowing my mind a little bit and so
let's go
from directly from there to the phones
let's talk to katie in my home state of
texas katie how are you
i'm doing all right john how are you i
am doing all right
well as well as well i'm not doing all
right well doing all right as well
so what can i what can i do to help
katie um
so i had to report a co-worker to hr
um because of a safety concern
and due to the nature of the report as
well as i know he has some
mental health issues um i think he's
going to know i'm the one who reported
him
and i wondered if you had any advice for
if
slash when he confronts me
so what was the nature of what you had
to report
um so he has some uh violent tendencies
in his past and he asked me how to find
a
firearm ah okay so
let me back up so wouldn't you say
violent tendencies in his past
tell me about that um self-harm i know
he's had some suicide attempts
okay and when he asked you about the gun
tell me about that conversation
um so it's sort of an open secret um
in my field i am um one of
a very few number of conservative people
and so it's kind of an open secret in my
office that i have a license to carry
and um you're in texas i thought they
that came with your birth certificate
right
you would think but no okay um
so he had come to me and he knows he
can't legally attain a firearm due to
some involuntary hospitalizations and
um so he asks hey do you know how i
could get around
these rules to get a firearm and
okay that panicked me a little bit in
the moment
and so then you took that information
and reported that request to hr
what happened next okay um to ask for
intervention
so um i reported it to my supervisor and
we went to hr together um
hr interviewed me and then um
i will not probably get an update about
his situation but i do know that they
went to
his boss to say hey this is happening
okay so there's a couple of thoughts i
have just off top of my head here and
this is a new one for me so i'm just
gonna
work through it out loud here um with
you on the line and
in front of the the live audience here
so
the first thing i would think is it
feels like a leap to me
that someone has some issues in the past
and they come to somebody who's a legal
gun owner and says hey how could i
i know i've got these challenges how
could i get around that so if they said
i want to get around that because i want
to hurt myself
or i've got somebody's gonna have to pay
i really need to get a gun
i that would that would for lack of you
know the
lack of better terms that would trigger
my arms right um
but the one plus one doesn't always
equal 2 there for me
the second thing is i'm trying to think
through an employment situation where
i've been a boss of a number of people
over the years
and i don't know that them inquiring
about how to get a gun
necessarily would invoke a violation of
any sort of work policy or that i need
to sit down and have a conversation
i might take a duly noted like all right
thanks for letting me know that
i'll keep an extra eye out maybe or
something like that but none of those
things that you're telling me
would suggest whoa we need to stop the
presses and bring that person in
unless there was some other concerns
that the workplace knew about
so well he had told me previously about
having fantasies of shooting a place
up ah there was something
so then you lay that one out there good
god almighty katie
next time lead with that one um so
yes um yeah
that changes all of it um yes good call
so you definitely need to go to your
bosses on that so now you've got
somebody who's got previous suicide
attempts
who um has violent past who
has told you you know i'm having some
fantasies about shooting the place up
and then comes you and says hey how can
i
illegally obtain a gun right now that is
one plus one plus one equals three you
definitely
did the right thing there um so
it sounds like this person trusts you
would that be fair or not fair i think
so yes
when you hear the word trust there's a
little bit of hesitation there tell me
about that
um so i personally i have my own have
had my own mental health issues i go to
a counselor i have depression
um but um i don't really
encourage his um
uh his sharing with me um just because
sometimes i find it to be a little
uncomfortable um
but um since since i i
reported him and everything um he has
shut down communications
with pretty much all the co-workers and
nobody has really talked to him so
i i think he did trust me okay is there
a chance that
um somebody else reported him
i'm not sure okay so here's what i would
recommend you do
uh if you feel safe all right all of
this what i'm gonna tell you is
is the contingent on you feeling safe
and that is
i think i'm a big believer that people
deserve an opportunity to have
a conversation when they
when they push past somebody's
boundaries and this push past your
boundary of comfortability right he told
you something that man i wish
number one if it was not by your hand
but it's in your lap he just dropped
something on you now you got to go deal
with it right
number two it involves a violation of a
relational
contract that y'all had and it's not a
written contract but it's one that's
just professional
you don't talk about shooting up the
workplace with your coworkers and then
you don't follow that up with
hey you know how i can illegally obtain
a firearm
so if this is me i am going to sit down
and let him know
i'd have a conversation with him if you
felt safe and say hey listen man you put
me in a position i just want you to know
that
i felt uncomfortable i didn't know what
to do and so i went and let my
supervisor know
um and so they might talk to you about
it
i want you to know like i'm not cool
with you talking about bringing guns
into work i'm not a person like i have
i'm a i'm a legal firearm holder
not an illegal firearm carrier and i'm
i'm not that person and i would suggest
that the relational breach
is on him not on you does that make
sense yes
when i say that you need to have a
conversation with him that's the that's
the what i would say is the responsible
dignified way to handle this
the the for lack of a terms the grown-up
way
how does that make you feel
um a little anxious i don't love
confrontation
which is probably why i took it to my
supervisor in the first place you bet
um but since we are all working from
home it would be a little easier
okay okay so that would that would
alleviate some of the the confrontation
there
here's the reality is if you think he
already knows it's you
there and there's already been a breach
of that relationship
from him to you i think the the adult
grown-up thing to do is to let him know
hey i'm gonna have to report this
um i had similar conversations with
co-workers not
anywhere near people wanting to shoot up
the building but
we had some i had some challenges at my
workplace at my previous workplace at my
previous workplace before that i've had
challenges here at ramsey solutions
people have had challenges with me
and they will pull me in a room and say
hey man like what you said in this
meeting
wasn't cool and i'm gonna have to let
somebody know i didn't like that
and i say cool thank you for letting me
know that and i've done the same thing
and so i think that's my hope is that we
could lean towards that's the way
grown-ups and adults interact with one
another also with an important caveat
that
there is a extra layer of fear and
trepidation when someone says hey i'm
considering shooting up the workplace or
i have fantasies about it
how do i get an illegal gun so i want
you to be very smart and intentional
about making sure you feel safe and this
is a safe context but at the end of the
day
if the conversation's been had the
conversation's been had i would also
recommend katie
role play this with your therapist you
have a counselor that you can
ask her or him to pretend hey pretend
you're my co-worker and i'm gonna sit
down and have this pretend conversation
it's a great place counseling can be a
great place we can practice social
interactions that are gonna be awkward
are gonna be challenging gonna be hard
uh in the future and so that may be a
great way to to role play this
so thank you for that call that's a
fascinating one katie i haven't thought
about that
and i also know that i answer a lot of
those questions i'm a big guy
i'm a big guy um if you're watching this
on youtube you can clearly see that i'm
i'm
super jacked particularly in my upper
body my arms are
massive and they're absolutely not at
all but um i honest
i understand that i have some of those
conversations out of privilege i'm not
worried about my physical safety and so
i don't mind pulling somebody aside
that's very different if you're a five
foot two female
in an office space somewhere or if
you've got somebody who
physically is threatening you so i get
the the privilege of me just saying hey
i'll just go talk to him but i do want
us all to
lean more towards man how do we have
hard conversations with people in our
offices how do we have hard
conversations with our loved ones let's
start
there and say hey this is a violation of
any part of our relationship
i don't like that you that you put me in
this position not cool man
um but thanks for the call katie that
was a good one so i want to
rotate here to a email that i got the
other day
so from susie it says my name is susie
and i'm 26 years old
i've paid off all my debt and i know
that i'm crushing it financially
however i'm struggling with contentment
i'm always making goals for myself
always on to the next thing and to be
honest it's exhausting and annoying that
i can't just
enjoy where i'm at and what i've
accomplished at such a young age
do you have any advice on how to slow
down and recognize my accomplishments
man susie this is i you've heard me talk
about this before this is one of the
great curses of our time
which is we have been trained since we
were little it used to just be boys and
now girls have been lumped in this too
where we are not defined by our innate
dignity and value we are not defined by
relationships we are now defined as
people by what you accomplish
how much money you make what you have in
your driveway and what you are wearing
and what your birthday party looked like
for some kid
on pinterest right we were defined by
all these accomplishments
and so what i want to strongly encourage
you to do susie is to find a core group
of friends
one two or three and this can sound like
a minimizer i'm not because it's this
easy and it's this hard
find a core group of friends you're 26
so i'm going to assume you've got some
friends
i want you to sit down with them and i
want you to say
we want to start being vulnerable i want
to start us being vulnerable with one
another
talking about the good things that are
going on in our life and the bad things
that are going on our life
the hard stuff and the good stuff um
there's a great philosopher that talks
about we are addicted to
be addicted to problems we're addicted
to going at things
but first right um instead of talking
about the good things that are going on
in our life
and so whenever we have good things we
just brush them off as yep and then we
go on to the next and we go into the
next
i want you to get a group of people be
vulnerable and say hey we're going to
celebrate the cool things that happened
this week
and what you're going to find is these
accomplishments in and of themselves are
hollow
what's not hollow is the relational
connection you have with other people
who will celebrate these things with you
who will cry with you who will come over
to your house and help you move
who will be there for you when your mom
passes away or your dad gets sick who
will be there for you when you have the
flu and you just need some soup
those are the things that begin to fill
us up from the inside out
these accomplishments and goals are our
ways of trying to make
external plugs to internal holes and it
will just never work
so susie the answer to your questions
about relationships start with a
vulnerability group of a couple of
good friends you have there in your
community great question i love it let's
go back to the phones let's go to aubry
in cleveland ohio
what's up aubry hey john thanks for
taking my call
thanks for calling my husband and i had
our daughter
two weeks ago after she was born we sent
out her
name and information that day and
immediately
uh we got a text asking us to change our
name
her name from my parents
hold on number one congratulations on
having a baby everybody's healthy
everybody's good
yeah we're great congratulations big
time that's awesome
number two what you got a text saying
change the name please
yeah well it's because her
grandmother my mom's grandmother was
evil and that was her first name
which we didn't know it was her first
name everyone called her by her middle
name but
it was the same as our daughters and
then the next day
my parents called and said that if we
kept the name my mom had
too much trauma to even be near the
child and she didn't know how she
couldn't
hurt the child if she was around it oh
good lord god almighty
what yeah so my mom and my younger
sister now don't want a relationship
because i wasn't willing to change the
name
because i'm hurting my mom and so my
husband and i we want to know did we do
the right thing
how do we create boundaries or gain
closure from not having them in our
lives
and then how do i save the relationship
with my little sister
um aubry listen i need you to hear
something that's happening right now
there are very few moments of my life
when i am speechless
when i am just sitting there with my
mouth a gape
wondering what in the world is going on
on planet earth and you have
i told someone the other day i think
i've seen it all and you have just
dropped a new one on me
so congratulations aubry this is a big
day for
me as a person this should be a big day
for you so you and your husband should
go out and celebrate just the fact that
you shut me up for a second so way to go
um number one first and foremost
you can name your baby truck driving
binoculars for all i care
you can name your baby i i mean
you can name your baby mars i think
didn't elon musk name his baby like a
bunch of like
consonants and letters and symbols or
whatever dude
aubrey you and your husband can name
your baby whatever you want
end of story closed close that fence
okay
number two what i've got to know what
evil means
was your grandma abusive was she a
murderer was she a witch like what what
was she what does that mean evil or was
she just like
you know said mean things or something
what does evil mean
yeah i think what we've heard just from
the stories is that she was manipulative
and controlling and
sometimes emotionally abusive but we
didn't really hear a lot of stories
about her
again if if my mom called me okay so my
daughter's name is josephine
um if my mom called me and said hey john
listen and by the way you don't send a
text with this type of
request you have a human conversation
so i my mom called me and said hey
listen you don't know this but your
great-grandma
was somebody who murdered children
that's just what she did
um she had a hatchet and she liked to go
murder children and her name was
josephine
and we were trying to remove that name
from our family tree
then i would say good lord mom thank you
for telling me
and i would sit down with my wife and
we'd have that conversation
if my mom said hey i had a great grandma
and that lady was manipulative and mean
and i don't like that name you're not
allowed to have that and she sent that
to me in a text i would say
well the name of our child is josephine
and that's the vr name
so that brings me to the second part
here's the deal you can't control
your mom you can't control your sister
and i hate that for you
that out of nowhere this type of
boundary
violation has popped up but there's not
a lot you can do to control
that type of external manipulation
my guess aubrey tell me if i'm wrong
here is there's other cracks in that dam
is that fair yeah
tell me some other things that have made
you uncomfortable relationally with your
mom
in recent past or in the very past
um i got divorced before i married my
husband
the second time and she stopped
talking to me for two years over that
yep
and she came back yeah okay
what about give me another one before
that
um so i have there's four of us and
when my brother had his child out of
wedlock and then my sister had his
her child out of wedlock she also
stopped talking to them for a few years
there you go i think it's a pattern of
behavior for her but
the whole her threatening to hurt a
child just we can't get over that
yeah and you should not get over that
hopefully you will never get over
somebody threatening to hurt your child
and moving forward you've got a mom
who uses her relationship as a weapon
right
and the only way to deal with something
like that is completely disengaged
and they don't get a role in your life
number two
somebody threatens to hurt your child
then that's when you let them know i'm
gonna
contact the police if i ever hear that
nonsense again you're not welcome around
my child
period end of story if in the future
which she will
she will come back and she will
recognize that that sort of weaponry
doesn't work with you
if she wants to take her relational ball
and go home in a huff and puff
like my four-year-old daughter does i'm
taking my doll and i'm leaving
as she wants to do that she will
recognize in short order whether it's a
year or two years or four months or
whatever
that that kind of nonsense doesn't work
with you that you and your husband are
tight and you have a great relationship
you're going to be a great mom and
you're moving forward together
and if that doesn't work that you will
come back and circle up
and at that point you're going to need
to revisit strongly and
very very directly aubry this idea of
you threatened my child
and i need to know what you meant by
that i need to make sure that there is
very clear boundaries between when you
are going to be with my child
and that you and or your husband will be
in that room in
any sort of hint at all about anything
it's called the police
period end of story i don't care if
she's your mom i don't care if she's
your sister i'll give you grandma i
don't care for whatever
right that's a no no one crosses that
beer year ever
as it comes to your sister tell me about
that relationship
it's actually pretty strong i mean i
took care of my sister
while my dad was in iraq and um
we we hang out quite a bit so i'm just
shocked
that she would take my mom's side and be
okay
she would that she's okay with changing
the name to just
make mom happy yeah i
those kind of relational dynamics
particularly with manipulative people
people are manipulative in that way like
your mama's being because it works
sometimes
and there may be some kind of big hook
small hook giant hook
sharp hook in your sister in this little
season she's in
and i wouldn't lose a lot of sleep over
that my guess is she'll circle back
because she knows that you love her she
knows that you care about her
and she knows that you've been there for
her and you will continue to be there
for her
i would leave an open door with my
sister and let her know that hey i love
you
my husband and i are sticking to this
name but i love you and i'd continue to
reach out to her
with some regularity but again at the
end of the day as hurtful as this is she
can choose to not be in relationship
with you she can choose to distance
herself and walk away from you
even over something as small and silly
as this
and when she does she does right and
that's going to hurt you and you'll need
to grieve that separation or that loss
with your husband or with a group of
friends because that's going to suck
but my guess is she's going to circle
back and probably
she's learned some of her relational
behavior from your mom right
and she learns that i can weaponize
myself and get people to do what i want
when i tell them that i'm just going to
disappear
people will jump sometimes and so that's
what she's got that's she's practicing
that on you
and i would keep strong on your
boundaries how's your new marriage how
do you like
you like this guy i love him he's my
best friend he's awesome
yeah do you guys have a good crew around
you do you have good friends you have
people who showed up to the hospital to
see this beautiful new baby
yeah they came over afterwards because
the hospital wouldn't let him in but
yeah
covet nonsense do you have a like a
church group or a softball group or some
friends there in your community
yes good so um i am big on family i am
big on reconciliation i'm also real big
on boundaries
and right now you guys have drawn drawn
the appropriate boundaries
and you have a group around you so
you're not isolated on a loan
um out on an island with this with this
awesome guy which would probably
be so bad he sounds like a great dude um
but man
god bless you god bless you aubrey uh go
forward and be strong
keep those connections with your friends
and your community
continue to nurture that relationship
and you've got a two-week-old beautiful
little baby
um man cherish every weird
uncomfortable second with that new baby
and
um when you get exhausted make sure that
that awesome husband of yours is there
to pick up the slack too you all work
together on that
congratulations moving forward i hate
that you didn't have
everyone rally around you to celebrate
this awesome moment
but it is what it is what it is thanks
for the call and congratulations you are
the first
i need to start keeping track of these
things man you're the first person to
completely uh stumped me for a second
there i liked it
so i want to go back um before i leave
before we wrap the show up today
i got an email from taylor but i've
asked i got a bunch of emails on this
question
which is how do i find a good therapist
what are the red flags that i should
look for
i typed up some notes here just thinking
through
what people should look for in a
counselor why counseling all that so
i want to run through a couple of these
real quick and if you have more
questions about
seeing a counselor am i seeing the right
one what is the
best modality what are things you like
all that kind of stuff shoot me an email
at askjohn ramseysolutions.com and i'll
continue to dig
into this one of my dreams here that
we're
working on as we speak is building a
network of
preferred counselors throughout the
country both in person
and digital and via like
zoom or skype and so i want to know what
you're thinking about counselors
good experiences bad experiences let me
know everything you've you've
experienced with counseling again at
askjohn
ramseysolutions.com just put in the
headline experience with
with counselors or questions about
therapists that would help
help us as we begin to to build out this
network
so here's the deal what is counseling
at the end of the day counseling is just
a professional
helping relationship that's it like you
go see a plumber
for professional help with plumbing a
counselor is or a therapist or a
psychologist
you used to be psychiatrists most
psychiatrists now are medical
or medicine dispensers there are still
some great ones left there
but they are professional helpers
marriage and family therapists
clinical social workers a good counselor
is not your friend
they are not your buddy they are not a
future romantic partner
and their job is not always to make you
feel good
hear me say that counseling will be
uncomfortable if it's done right it will
challenge you if it's done right a
counselor's job is to walk alongside you
and help gently point you to other
directions
that you may not have considered walking
in because whatever's working
not working in your life could be better
on the other side of a different road of
a different avenue on a different bridge
whatever that may look like
they help you see challenges that you
might have missed or that you are
avoiding another thing a counselor does
they reflect back to you the way they
experience
you in a session this is often how you
interact with the outside world one of
my favorite
therapy instructors ever is ervin yalum
and he talks about
everything in a session is data and so
if i find myself as a counselor after
the session three
and you start talking and i'm like oh my
gosh this is getting boring
that's an important moment for a
therapist to reflect back do you bore
the people
in your life is it hard for people to be
around you
do they get frustrated with you because
you talk low and low energy and you kind
of are e
or you bring a room down right so
everything is data so a counselor is
going to reflect back to you
or do you bring sexual energy to
everything do you bring this
fake excitement to everything do you
talk so so much
a counselor is going to reflect back to
you the way they experience you in a
session
and that's going to lead to the next
thing they should then teach you new
skills on how to relate to the outside
world
because most everything every
challenge you have mental health
challenges um
uh personal challenges personal
development
issues problems at work problems with
bosses
come back to broken or hurting or
fractured relationships
and so a good counselor is going to
teach you how to interact in
relationship teach you how to interact
with the outside world
as a series of steps a counselor should
also call you on your bs
when they're teaching you these skills
right they should tell you that's not
factual
that's not how that works they should
you should have a good enough rapport
that you trust them enough to be honest
with you
if you cannot hear honest feedback let
your counselor know that and they'll
they'll work with you
i subscribe to terry real's idea he's
one of the most extraordinary
relationship therapists in the world
that a counselor should not always be
neutral
they should tell you the truth if you're
going with a couple the counselor should
be able to say
hey husband you're being an idiot right
now hey wife you are using
a one down position to drag use your
power to drag down this whole
relationship into a
landmines right i do think there's
moments when counselors should not be
neutral and they should tell you the
truth and lean in against you if they
need to
here's some important things about
counseling go three or four sessions
before you bail
don't just go one and be like i don't
like them they're weird they're annoying
don't go two and say nothing's happening
yet um don't just stop going session
three and four is often when things
start to turn when things start to click
when should you go to counseling i
recommend that everyone can benefit from
a neutral third party in their life
i just think they can a mentor a guide
someone that you totally trust who will
help you
someone you can be totally vulnerable
with this could be a counselor
a mentor a support group like i said
counselors are professionals right
if i've got a plumbing issue i've got
some buddies that know how to do some
some minor plumbing they can come help
me
put in a sprinkler line or something if
i need to fix my sewer main
i'm going to call a professional i don't
want to deal with it i'm going to pay
the money i'm going to get the warranty
on it
that's what i'm talking about going to
see a counselor if you're struggling
with like hey my wife and i had a fight
last night
man call you call somebody that you
trust go have coffee i'll process it out
and if they're a trustworthy good friend
you can be vulnerable with man have that
conversation
if it's deeper than that call call a
professional
one of my mentors dr aretha marbley and
dr brett hendricks me two important
people in my life said that most people
wait to go to counseling until there's a
crisis
don't wait until the house is on fire
before you go check things out
one of them suggested most people wait
to go to counseling until there's a
crisis
is similar to waiting till you have the
flu to start a workout program
right that's the worst time if things
are going pretty good that's a good time
when you're healthy you're feeling right
go see somebody then right
i think everyone thinking about getting
married or having a long-term
partnership with somebody should engage
in
counseling just having somebody else
talk about questions you haven't even
thought about
yet if you have major trauma that you're
having trouble processing
go see somebody not everyone who has a
tragedy needs a therapist i hear that
all the time hey my son or daughter had
somebody die
in their classroom in middle school i
need to get into a counselor right not
necessarily
not necessarily one of the rules of
trauma response is
most people don't need you most of the
time when they're talking about a crisis
responder or a therapist but sometimes
they do
if you find yourself unable to sleep
unable to grieve
you find yourself withdrawing and alone
you realize that netflix is much more
likely you're
much more likely to hang out with
netflix than you are with the people
that you love
a counselor could be a great blessing
there things to watch out for
you should not be in counseling forever
a counselor's job is to walk alongside
you
help you and send you on your way both
folks that i have met with for
any length of time the first thing they
told me in the session was my job is to
work myself
out of a job with you and that's how i
knew i got the right person
i got the right person there i am a big
believer
outside of you have to do this for
insurance purposes and that's a whole
other conversation we can have some day
i don't like diagnosis in the first
session
they don't know you they haven't
experienced you i don't even like them
in the first few sessions because
what presents as a quote unquote
diagnosis tends to be an ecosystem issue
it tends to be a giant process
issue outside of a very few like bipolar
disorder
or schizophrenia or major depressive
disorder some of these big ones
um if they are a jerk walk out the door
counseling is about the relationship
period right
if you aren't gelling after three or
four sessions let them know hey this
relationship isn't working for me they
should have big boy girl and pants and
say cool
thank you for letting me know and then
go find somebody else right
a trained therapist should not ask you
to dig into the details of your trauma
in the first session either you should
work into that over several sessions
after you two have discussed a safety
plan how you will cope etc
last thing is where do you find a
counselor they're everywhere they're
online
local college towns have interns ask a
friend churches often have free
counselors
community counseling centers have free
or low-cost individual family counseling
and then there's just websites in your
local community
there are i don't know like referrals
for yelp and i mean their
counselors are everywhere particularly
since covet
since cove had launched um there have
been
way more counselors who put their
practices online and really have
have people in rural communities can see
therapists now it's just kind of spread
out so
that's some thoughts on counseling how
to find a therapist what's a good
therapist when to leave therapy
if you've got more questions again email
me at askjohn ramseysolutions.com
and so as we wrap up the show today i'm
going to pull up the
the lyric of the day here
we're a couple of shows in now right
where a couple of shows in
and i've i've been vulnerable with you
i've shown you my heart
i've told you about some of the greatest
performers of all time
but this is really the one this is the
one that when people say delony what's
the greatest song ever written
what's the greatest songwriter of all
time i smile
my eyes glisten i'll get a tear i have
those occasions i'll get a tear
and i'll think back to the 1973 album
i can't really think back that was
before i was born but i go back to this
1973 album that i heard later on in my
life
and i think about this guy named bill
his friends called him billy
and he had two first names as a first
name and last name
mr billy joel in his classic
1973 song piano man where he says
son can you play me a memory i'm not
really sure how it goes but it's sad and
it's sweet and i knew it complete when i
wore a younger man's clothes
and the waitress is practicing politics
and the businessmen
slowly get stoned yes they're sharing a
drink they call
loneliness but it's better than drinking
alone
sing us a song or the piano man sing us
a song
tonight we're all in the mood for a
melody and you've got us feeling
all right this is the dr john dolone
show
[Music]
you